the weather's heating up
people are going to be jumping into
pools but they could be diving into the
deep end
of legal troubles if certain safety
precautions aren't taken that is the
topic
of today's la vegas now segment with
eric palacios
so eric what are my responsibilities or
homeowners responsibilities when it
comes to pool safety
well you've got to be careful if you
have guests especially
little kids miners you have to make uh
your
house your backyard your pool especially
uh safe
for them reasonably safe and the first
part of this is making sure that you're
not in violation of any codes
so what are some things that could make
you liable when it comes to injuries in
your pool
one of the first things we see is uh
code requires that there be a
self-closing gate
a lot of times these are spring
activated so even if you forget to close
it
the door will close automatically behind
you if this
uh device has is old or rusted or broken
and the gates don't close then this can
lead
to little kids coming into your backyard
and then falling in the pool getting
hurt
and you can be liable for this also if
you
don't pay attention to guests in your
house
uh little kids if you leave them
unaccompanied or in the care of
older kids but they're also on their
phones on their devices and not paying
attention
and something happens you can be held
liable and responsible for this
yeah a lot of kids going back and forth
to different homes even
if you don't have a pool in your home
what happens
legally speaking if someone is injured
on your property
well the good news is normally uh
homeowners insurance takes care of this
in case that there's a complaint file
that you're sued or there's a claim made
if you own the home you normally have a
policy that will protect you
if you rent a home it's always good to
have renters insurance to make sure
you're covered in the event
that there's negligence and something
happens to a guest a
family member or a friend that is
visiting but it's always important to
just
make sure that the house is safe that
you're looked at things that need
repair and if there's kids there
that are invited over uh that you keep
an eye on them or you
make sure that their parents keep an eye
on them while they're at your house
one other piece of advice you have is
regarding something that i probably
wouldn't have thought of and that's
doggy doors
yes it's very sad but almost every
summer
uh we see that a toddler uh
generally just still crawling will will
go through the doggy door
and if the family has a pool uh all it
takes is seconds for that uh baby that
child to fall in the pool
uh and if especially if the door is
closed and the babysitter or parents
grandparents they don't have a clue that
this is a possibility
so they'll tend to not look for the
child sometimes for 10 minutes 15
minutes 20 minutes all of a sudden they
notice hey the house is quiet what's
going on
and if the child crawls through the
doggy door and there's a pool
uh it's it can just lead to horrible
horrible
results so if you have a doggie door
especially if you have a bigger dog
uh it's very important that you keep it
closed you keep an eye on it
or that you put something outside of it
so in case uh
someone does get out from it they're
still uh blocked in and
can't access the pool well i certainly
hope that everyone has a
very safe and enjoyable summer eric
always good to talk to you great advice
thank you very much
thank you for having me we'll see you
soon if you want more information you
can give eric palacios and associates a
call
at that phone number 702-444-7777